This past year, technology has been the glue that's kept many of our relationships alive. Birthday parties and business meetings moved to Zoom, and we kept up with friends and acquaintances who we could no longer see in person with Facebook updates, FaceTime, and group text messages. Now, even as life begins to return to normal, technology-mediated communication is here to stay. Although offices are starting to reopen, many workplaces plan to allow teleworking to continue, which will mean those dreaded Zoom meetings are not. going away. But even before the pandemic, we were already relying heavily on social media to
过去这一年，科技成为了维系我们许多人际关系的纽带。生日派对和商务会议搬到了Zoom上，我们通过Facebook动态、FaceTime和群聊短信与无法亲身见面的朋友和熟人保持联系。现在，即使生活开始回归正常，这种以科技为媒介的交流方式也将长期存在。尽管办公室开始重新开放，但许多工作场所计划继续允许远程办公，这意味着那些令人头疼的Zoom会议并不会消失。但即使在疫情之前，我们就已经非常依赖社交媒体来
keep us connected. Facebook alone has 2.8 billion monthly active users, and 85% of Americans now own a smartphone. More and more, when we talk to each other, we do it with some kind of technology between us. So what does this mean for human communication? Is the version of ourselves that we present on social media, authentic and truthful? Are people more likely to lie online or in a text message than they are in person, to video calls exhaust us more than in-person conversations do, and perhaps more broadly, is all of this technology-driven communication good for our mental health and well-being or not? Welcome to Speaking of Psychology, the flagship podcast of the American Psychological Association that examines the links between psychological science and everyday life.
保持联系了。仅Facebook每月就有28亿活跃用户，如今85%的美国人拥有智能手机。我们彼此交谈时，越来越多地通过某种科技手段进行。那么，这对人类交流意味着什么？我们在社交媒体上展示的那个版本的自己是真实可信的吗？人们在网上或短信中撒谎的可能性是否比面对面交流时更高？视频通话是否比面对面交谈更让我们疲惫？更广泛地说，所有这些由科技驱动的交流对我们的心理健康和幸福感究竟是有益还是有害？欢迎收听《心理学谈话》，这是美国心理学会的旗舰播客，旨在探讨心理科学与日常生活之间的联系。
I'm Kim Mills. Our guest today is Dr. Jeff Hancock, a psychologist and professor in the Department of Communication at Stanford University. where he founded and directs the Stanford social media lab. Dr. Hancock is an expert in social media behavior and the psychology of online interaction. He is well known for his research on how people lie and whether we can detect deception in texts, emails, or in online reviews. His TED talk on deception has been viewed more than one million times. He's also studied how social media affects well-being and how artificial intelligence is changing the way we talk to one another. Thank you for joining us, Dr. Hancock.
我是金·米尔斯。我们今天的嘉宾是杰夫·汉考克博士，他是斯坦福大学传播系的心理学家和教授，并在那里创立并指导了斯坦福社交媒体实验室。汉考克博士是社交媒体行为和在线互动心理学方面的专家。他因研究人们如何撒谎以及我们是否能识破短信、电子邮件或在线评论中的欺骗行为而闻名。他关于欺骗的TED演讲观看次数已超过一百万次。他还研究了社交媒体如何影响幸福感，以及人工智能如何改变我们彼此交谈的方式。感谢您参加我们的节目，汉考克博士。
Thanks, Kim. I'm excited to be here. So as I said, the name of your research group is the Stanford Social Media Lab. For a lot of people, when they think of social media, they think about Twitter or LinkedIn or Facebook or Instagram. You study those. But you also have a broader definition of what social media is. Can you explain that? Right, yeah. In fact, I had a social media lab at Cornell before there was social media, so speak. Because for me, social media is any technology that we use to be social with one another.
谢谢，金。很高兴来到这里。正如我所说，您的研究小组名为斯坦福社交媒体实验室。对很多人来说，提到社交媒体，他们会想到Twitter、LinkedIn、Facebook或Instagram。您研究这些，但您对社交媒体的定义似乎更广泛。能解释一下吗？没错，是的。事实上，在社交媒体出现之前，我就在康奈尔大学有一个社交媒体实验室了。因为对我来说，社交媒体是我们用来进行社交的任何技术。
So I'm really interested in human-to-human communication when there's some technology between us. But even more broadly, you know, if you're talking to a robot in a way, I think of that as social media. When you're interacting with your car, that's a form of social media. And you and I here on a video conference, to me, is social media as well. So let's talk about something that falls under that broader umbrella, which is video chat. Your research into Zoom fatigue has gotten quite a bit of recent media coverage. What exactly is Zoom fatigue and why should we find it so exhausting to just sit in front of a computer screen and talk to other people? Well, that's exactly the question that my colleague Jeremy Bounce and I had when the pandemic first started and us faculty members had all this extra time because we didn't have to commute.
所以我对人与人之间通过某种技术进行的交流非常感兴趣。但更广泛地说，如果你在和机器人对话，我认为这也属于社交媒体。当你与汽车互动时，那也是一种社交媒体。而你和我在这里进行视频会议，对我来说也是社交媒体。那么，让我们谈谈这个更广泛范畴下的一个话题，即视频聊天。您对“Zoom疲劳”的研究最近引起了不少媒体报道。究竟什么是Zoom疲劳？为什么仅仅坐在电脑屏幕前与他人交谈会让我们感到如此疲惫？嗯，这正是疫情刚开始时，我和我的同事杰里米·拜伦森提出的问题。当时我们这些教职员工因为不用通勤，多了很多额外的时间。
We weren't going into the lab. Meetings were getting canceled left and right, but everything went to Zoom. And we found ourselves having these conversations, but why would this be so tiring? You know, we're here, relaxed. you know, we're in our homes. And so what we started to look at were the kind of differences between Zoom conferences and face-to-face. And looking back, there was, you know, a lot of work in the 90s. My colleague here at Stanford, Pam Hines had done work on video conferencing and why they might be more fatiguing.
我们不去实验室了，会议一个接一个地取消，但所有事情都转到了Zoom上。我们发现自己一直在进行这些对话，但为什么会这么累呢？你知道，我们在这里，很放松，在家里。所以我们开始研究Zoom会议与面对面交流之间的差异。回顾过去，90年代有很多相关研究。我在斯坦福的同事帕姆·海恩斯曾做过关于视频会议以及为什么它们可能更令人疲劳的研究。
But it sort of research died out to some degree because it wasn't, you know, a huge deal. People weren't using video conferences all the time. It was there if you wanted it, but most people didn't use it. So what we started to talk about was this general feeling of kind of exhaustion or tiredness. Sometimes afterwards, you know, Jeremy would say, I just don't feel like doing anything afterwards. Or I would say, I don't want to talk to anybody after that. So we found some sort of consensus on this idea that maybe Zoom meetings aren't necessarily more fatiguing than face-to-face, but have some unique fatigue. we think it's related to some of the nonverbal dynamics.
但这类研究在某种程度上中断了，因为当时它并不是什么大不了的事。人们并没有一直使用视频会议。如果你想用它就在那里，但大多数人并不使用。所以我们开始讨论这种普遍的疲惫感。有时事后，杰里米会说：“我之后什么都不想做。”或者我会说：“那之后我不想和任何人说话。”所以我们对这个观点达成了一些共识：也许Zoom会议并不一定比面对面交流更令人疲劳，但它确实有一些独特的疲劳感。我们认为这与一些非语言动态有关。
So Jeremy laid this out in one of his articles really nicely. The fact that your face right now is really close to mine. It's almost like at an intimate level. And that's sort of physiologically arousing. Either we're going to be, you know, come to blows or we're going to have a kiss, right? Like it's just, it's very unusual for us to be this close. When we're on with lots of people, even if I'm not speaking, it feels like a lot of people are staring at us, something that we've called hypergays. And to me, then, one of the biggest ones psychologically
杰里米在他的一篇文章中很好地阐述了这一点。你现在的脸离我非常近，几乎达到了亲密的程度。这在生理上会引起唤醒。我们要么会打架，要么会接吻，对吧？我们离得这么近是非常不寻常的。当我们和很多人在一起时，即使我不说话，也感觉很多人在盯着我们，我们称之为“过度凝视”。对我来说，心理上最大的一个因素是
is the mirror. So right now I'm speaking to you. I can see myself. In fact, my image is as big as yours. And while we've seen ourselves in the mirror before, we've never really seen ourselves socially behaving. When we go into the bathroom and check ourselves out, it's usually just for appearance, but not for how we behave. This has a huge impact on us, I think, and is very tiring. And I've been trying to track myself just how much time I look at my image versus yours. And so it's hard to do this kind of introspection. But I'm guessing it's about half the time.
镜子。此刻我正在和你说话，我能看到我自己。事实上，我的图像和你的一样大。虽然我们以前在镜子里见过自己，但我们从未真正见过自己进行社交行为的样子。当我们去洗手间照镜子时，通常只是为了看外表，而不是看我们的行为。我认为这对我们影响巨大，而且非常累人。我一直在尝试追踪自己看自己图像的时间与看你图像的时间对比。进行这种内省很难，但我猜大约是一半的时间。
My attention is drawn back to my image. So these are some of the examples of why Zoom can be so fatiguing. Let's turn for a moment to your research on deception and lying. Your TED talk that I mentioned a moment ago is called The Future of Lying. What is the future of lying? How will it be different from its past?
我的注意力被拉回到了自己的图像上。所以这些就是Zoom为何如此令人疲劳的一些例子。让我们转到您关于欺骗和撒谎的研究。我刚才提到的您的TED演讲题目是《撒谎的未来》。撒谎的未来是什么样的？它将如何与过去不同？
That is a really great question. For me, I was interested in how technology could change how often we lie, and then how we sort of end up trusting other people. Kind of two sides of the same coin in a way. When we first started looking at it, we would ask people like, where do they think people would lie the most? And what we found was this sort of folk theory that as soon as you couldn't see the other person, as soon as you couldn't hear the other person, line would go up. And it's sort of this nonverbal cue idea that if I, if I can't see them, then they can lie more easily and therefore they will. And it's wrong, it turns out, on a whole bunch of levels. And I think the most recent work that I think is the best on deception detection in general is Tim Levine's and it's summarized in his book, duped. And what we find when it comes to technology is his ideas from duped work perfectly. So the first is that most of the time, most people don't want to lie, right?
这是一个非常好的问题。对我来说，我感兴趣的是科技如何改变我们撒谎的频率，以及我们最终如何信任他人。这在某种程度上是同一枚硬币的两面。当我们刚开始研究时，我们会问人们：他们认为人们在什么情况下最容易撒谎？我们发现了一种民间理论，即一旦你看不到对方，听不到对方，撒谎就会增加。这是一种非语言线索的观点，即如果我看不到他们，他们就能更容易地撒谎，因此他们就会撒谎。事实证明，这在很多层面上都是错误的。我认为目前关于欺骗检测最好的研究是蒂姆·莱文的，他的观点总结在《被骗》一书中。当我们谈到科技时，他书中的观点非常适用。首先，大多数时候，大多数人不想撒谎，对吧？
the best option usually is to tell the truth. And sometimes we're in positions where that's uncomfortable or awkward or could be harmful for us. And that doesn't really change when we go into technology. And I should also clarify that I'm not talking about the Russian spies or the scam artist, you know, the Prince from Nigeria or any of those folks. Instead, I'm talking about people that we know, people that we have a tie with. And in that case, it looks like the psychology really drives line, not
最好的选择通常是说实话。有时我们处于不舒服、尴尬或可能对自己有害的境地。当我们使用科技时，这一点并没有真正改变。我还应该澄清，我说的不是俄罗斯间谍或诈骗犯，比如来自尼日利亚的王子之类的人。相反，我指的是我们认识的人，我们有联系的人。在这种情况下，看起来是心理驱动了撒谎，而不是
the technology. So we found that people will be just as likely to lie in technologically needed places as others, except there was one big difference, and that is when the technology left a record. So in some of our earliest work, we found that people would lie the least in emails. And emails are one of these, like, really recorded ones. So if I send you an email, not only do you have a copy of the lie I just sent you, but there's also ones on servers and everything. So most of the time, psychology is what's going to drive whether someone lies or not, not the technology, but there are some features. So if there's a record, people tend to think about that a little bit. Another one is whether we're synchronous or not. So when I'm face to face with you,
技术。所以我们发现，人们在科技媒介环境下的撒谎可能性与其他环境下一样，除了一个重大区别，那就是当技术留下了记录时。在我们最早的一些研究中，我们发现人们在电子邮件中撒谎最少。电子邮件是那种真正有记录的媒介。如果我给你发一封电子邮件，不仅你有一份我刚才发给你的谎言的副本，服务器上也有，到处都有。所以大多数时候，心理才是驱动一个人是否撒谎的原因，而不是技术，但技术确实有一些特征。如果有记录，人们往往会多考虑一点。另一个因素是我们是否同步。所以当我面对面和你交流时，
there's only so much I can pause. Like if I pause more than a second, it gets kind of weird and you start to worry that maybe I'm having a stroke or something. And so we have to think of things really fast and so line occurs more often synchronously. Technology can give us a bit of a break on that and sometimes we even see that people are more honest in those places. So I think the future of lying is one that will be driven primarily by psychology. So do we have the need to lies or other options? Also by some of these affordances of technology like will there be a record of this or not. And so that will just continue to evolve. Now in our latest work, what we're seeing is, is that people are getting really good at lying, even in recorded media.
我能停顿的时间是有限的。如果我停顿超过一秒，就会变得很奇怪，你可能会担心我是不是中风了之类的。所以我们必须很快地思考，因此同步交流中撒谎发生得更频繁。技术可以让我们在这方面稍微喘口气，有时我们甚至发现人们在那些媒介中更诚实。所以我认为撒谎的未来将主要由心理驱动。我们是否有撒谎的需要，或者是否有其他选择？同时也受到技术的一些可供性影响，比如这是否有记录。所以这将继续演变。现在在我们最新的研究中，我们看到人们即使在有记录的媒介中也变得非常擅长撒谎。
And there, you just choose the kind of lies you can do. So, for example, a student could say to me, you know, Professor Hancock, my printer's not working. And that's an okay lie in an email, because the chance of me going to his place and checking out his printer is almost zero. But if he were to lie and say something about when he submitted something, right? And then there's a record that can check that, then he's going to be in trouble. Are there, have you done comparisons among various media?
在那里，你只是选择你可以撒的谎。例如，一个学生可以对我说：“汉考克教授，我的打印机坏了。”在电子邮件中这是一个可以接受的谎言，因为我去他家检查他打印机的可能性几乎为零。但如果他撒谎说关于他提交某样东西的时间，对吧？然后有记录可以核实，那他就会有麻烦。您是否对各种媒介进行过比较？
Are we more likely to lie via text or in person or over the phone? I mean, how do we lie differently in different situations? Right, great question. So we've done a number of these different kinds of studies. We use diary studies where we get people to record them. We've looked at log records, lots of different ways. And what we end up finding is that text and email typically have fewer lies than, say, phone calls. And it's because of that record.
我们更容易通过短信、面对面还是电话撒谎？我的意思是，我们在不同情况下撒谎的方式有何不同？没错，好问题。我们做过许多这类不同的研究。我们使用日记研究，让人们记录下来。我们查看了日志记录，用了许多不同的方法。我们最终发现，短信和电子邮件通常比电话通话的谎言更少。这是因为有记录。
It's because we're not forced to say things really quickly. And it's sort of been hard to talk about it lately because with disinformation, everybody just thinks that once you're on the internet, everything is a lie. And it's true that there is a lot of deception online, but I try to differentiate between what I call the known network, so people that we have a tie with, and the unknown network. So that could be, anyway, from the Russian spy to just somebody who's just somebody who's a known network. trying to troll me to someone trying to scam me. And it's difficult sometimes to differentiate those. So is there a lot of disinformation online? Yes, it's a real major problem. But is that happening
这是因为我们不需要被迫很快地回答。最近谈论这个问题有点困难，因为随着虚假信息的出现，每个人都认为一旦上了互联网，一切都是谎言。确实网上有很多欺骗行为，但我试图区分我所说的“已知网络”（即我们有联系的人）和“未知网络”。这可能包括从俄罗斯间谍到只是试图骚扰我或诈骗我的人。有时很难区分这些。那么网上有很多虚假信息吗？是的，这是一个非常严重的问题。但这种情况会发生在
between, say, Jeff and Kim, who have a professional relationship? No, very unlikely. In those kind of situations, we see line is more likely to be done on the phone, so vocally, or face-to-face, than it will be in an email or text message. What's been most surprising to you, you while studying the impact of technology online? Well, it was definitely the fact that people were lying the least in email, for example, one of our first studies. I remember just I don't, you know, it was really strange. And then when we started thinking about it and thinking about this idea of the record,
比如杰夫和金之间吗？我们有职业关系。不会，非常不可能。在那种情况下，我们发现撒谎更有可能发生在电话里，也就是口头上，或者面对面，而不是在电子邮件或短信中。在研究科技对在线影响的过程中，什么最让您感到惊讶？嗯，绝对是人们在电子邮件中撒谎最少的事实，例如，这是我们最早的研究之一。我记得……我不知道，这真的很奇怪。然后当我们开始思考它，并想到这个“记录”的概念时，
once you think of that, it's just, it's so obvious. But I think a lot of deception detection research up until the 2000s were really focused on nonverbal cues. You know, this is the influence of Paul Ekman. and his colleagues and students that we really focused on nonverbal things and it made it into the pop culture now it's pretty clear that there aren't any really strong pinocchio noses there's no one cue that will always tell you somebody's line so the fact that it happens you know online versus face-to-face the nonverbals are just less important and instead it's some of these affordances of online like the record that we leave behind
一旦你想到这一点，它就太显而易见了。但我认为2000年以前的许多欺骗检测研究确实集中在非语言线索上。你知道，这是保罗·埃克曼及其同事和学生的影响，我们确实专注于非语言的东西，它现在已经进入了流行文化。现在很清楚，并没有什么真正的“匹诺曹鼻子”，没有哪一个线索能总是告诉你某人在撒谎。所以它在网上还是面对面发生，非语言线索的重要性只是降低了，取而代之的是在线技术的一些可供性，比如我们留下的记录。
There's this idea that we're all envious of each other these days, not because people necessarily lie on social media, but because they present the best, most idealized vision of themselves with touched-up selfies or elegant dinners or beautiful vacation photos rather than the day-to-day drudgery. Is the way that people present themselves on social media authentic, or is that not authentic? Is that a big lie? This is one of the biggest complaints people have about social media that it's all just like people showing their greatest stuff. And I guess I have two big responses to that. One is that when we talk to people that we've just gotten to know or we see on the street or we see, you know, back in the pre-air in the hallway, we would not talk about all the crappy things or boring things that happened about us. We would say, hey, I just went skiing this weekend or I did that. that is we're always presenting a version of ourselves. And I don't think that's inauthentic.
现在有一种观点认为我们都在嫉妒彼此，不是因为人们在社交媒体上撒谎，而是因为他们展示了自己最好、最理想的一面，比如修图后的自拍、优雅的晚餐或美丽的度假照片，而不是日常的琐碎。人们在社交媒体上展示自己的方式是真实的，还是不真实的？这是一个弥天大谎吗？这是人们对社交媒体最大的抱怨之一，即人们只是在展示他们最棒的东西。我想对此我有两个主要的回答。第一，当我们和刚认识的人交谈，或者在街上看到，或者在疫情前在走廊里遇到时，我们也不会谈论所有发生在我们身上的糟糕或无聊的事情。我们会说：“嘿，我这个周末去滑雪了”或者“我做了那个”。也就是说，我们总是在展示一个版本的自己。我不认为这是不真实的。
Instead, I think people are saying, here's what I want to project, here's what I value, here's me with my friends, or here's me traveling. And so, okay, is it a better part of themselves? Is it them looking the best of the 50 photos they took? Yeah. But this is also like a sweater that I'm wearing that I like. I think I look good in.
相反，我认为人们是在说：“这是我想投射的形象，这是我所珍视的，这是我和朋友在一起，或者这是我在旅行。”所以，好吧，这是他们更好的一面吗？这是他们从拍的50张照片中选出的最好的一张吗？是的。但这就像我穿的一件我喜欢的毛衣，我觉得我穿起来很好看。
I'm not here in my like underwear. I can attest to that. So is this authentic? This is an audio podcast, but he's telling the truth. I am clothed. And, you know, sure, in the Zoom area, maybe we're coming more often in pajamas, but we still think about our presentation. So I think that we're able to do more kinds of optimized presentation online,
我不是穿着内衣在这里。我可以证明这一点。所以这是真实的吗？这是一个音频播客，但他说了实话。我确实穿了衣服。而且，你知道，当然，在Zoom时代，也许我们穿睡衣的次数更多，但我们仍然会考虑我们的形象展示。所以我认为我们能够在网上进行更多种类的优化展示，
but I don't think it's necessarily authentic. And my colleague, Sandra Mats, has done some really nice recent work showing that some people can present really authentically online. and it turns out online behavior and being engaged a lot can be really healthy for them, high well-being. Other people report behaving online in a sort of inauthentic way where they're saying, oh, I did post that, but that's not really who I am or that's not, you know, I only did that once.
但我认为这并不一定是不真实的。我的同事桑德拉·马茨最近做了一些非常好的研究，表明有些人可以在网上表现得非常真实。事实证明，在线行为和积极参与对他们来说可能非常健康，幸福感很高。其他人则报告说在网上表现得有些不真实，他们会说：“哦，我确实发了那个，但那不是真正的我”或者“那不是……你知道，我只做过一次。”
And that can make them actually feel bad afterwards. So I also think we can move away from, you know, social media being all one thing or the other for everyone and start to understand that, you know, if I behave in an inauthentic way, That can have some negative ramifications for me. But if I'm behaving authentically online, it can be really powerful. There's been a lot of worry and articles about whether smartphones and social media are addictive and whether they cause depression or anxiety, especially when we're talking about kids and teens. Are these worries justified?
这实际上会让他们事后感觉不好。所以我认为我们也可以摆脱“社交媒体对每个人来说要么全是好的一面，要么全是坏的一面”这种看法，开始理解：如果我的行为是不真实的，那可能会对我产生一些负面影响。但如果我在网上表现得真实，那可能会非常有力量。关于智能手机和社交媒体是否会让人上瘾，以及它们是否会导致抑郁或焦虑，尤其是在谈论儿童和青少年时，有很多担忧和文章。这些担忧有道理吗？
Let me start by saying these are really prevalent worries. Any parent group I talk to, any professional group like educators, friends and family with kids, This is a serious concern because I think everyone sees kids, especially with the pandemic, on a lot of screen time. And even before the pandemic, my colleague Nicole Ells and I were going to have a book proposal about why we wanted to bring down the anxiety. One reason is there's not a lot of great evidence that using social media is automatically good or bad for you.
首先，这些担忧确实非常普遍。我交谈过的任何家长团体、任何像教育工作者这样的专业团体、有孩子的亲朋好友，这都是一个严重的担忧，因为我认为每个人都看到孩子们，特别是在疫情期间，花了很多时间在屏幕上。甚至在疫情之前，我和我的同事妮可·埃尔斯就打算写一本关于为什么要降低焦虑的书。原因之一是，没有太多强有力的证据表明使用社交媒体自动对你有益或有害。
Instead, our survey of the literature is that it depends much more on what you're doing. So if you spend an hour connecting with an old friend or interacting with buddies on a video game or whatever you're doing on your phone, that can be really psychologically healthy. If you're doing something that's not like, say, stalking an X or obsessing on something and using social media to do that, then that can be psychologically unhealthy. So in our review of the literature, this is with my colleagues at the Stanford Social Media Lab, we looked at over 200 studies, over 200,000 particular. dispense in all these studies. And we can basically meta-analyze it so that you say how much social
相反，我们对文献的调查显示，这更多取决于你在做什么。所以，如果你花一个小时与老朋友联系，或者在视频游戏中与伙伴互动，或者在手机上做任何事情，那在心理上可能非常健康。如果你做的事情不是这样，比如跟踪前任或对某事着迷并利用社交媒体做这些，那在心理上可能是不健康的。所以在我们对文献的回顾中，这是我和斯坦福社交媒体实验室的同事一起做的，我们查看了200多项研究，超过20万名参与者。我们基本上可以进行元分析，这样你就可以说一个人在研究中使用了多少社交
media use a person was having in the study and then whatever measure of well-being. And there's many types. We tracked six things from like depression and loneliness, but also social connectedness and life satisfaction. When we did that huge giant study, the effect size was R equals 0.01, which is essentially zero. It's a very precise estimate of zero. So does that mean for all the parents out there like, hey, don't worry about it? You know, Professor Hancock says it's not a problem. I don't think that's exactly what I would be saying, but I would say there isn't evidence for you to be really anxious and worried. Instead, what I would think about is for your child and your family, how is this person's use of technology working?
媒体，然后看幸福感的任何衡量标准。类型有很多。我们追踪了六件事，从抑郁和孤独，到社会联系和生活满意度。当我们做那项巨大的研究时，效应量是R=0.01，这本质上是零。这是一个非常精确的零估计。那么这对所有的家长来说意味着什么？“嘿，别担心。汉考克教授说这不是问题。”我不认为这就是我会说的，但我会说，没有证据让你感到非常焦虑和担忧。相反，我会考虑的是，对于你的孩子和你的家庭，这个人的科技使用方式是否有效？
And so I have some friends that kids are doing really well. They're thriving in the pandemic. They're learning all these computer skills and their friends are working with them to do better at homework. and to stay connected. Others have really struggled and I think this is another place we're getting where we need to move away from averages and start looking at individuals and there's really great work coming out of Europe in this sort of it's called the awesome well-being project where they're taking an end of one approach where they're finding that some young people indeed about it is about 10
所以我有一些朋友的孩子做得很好。他们在疫情中茁壮成长。他们正在学习所有这些计算机技能，他们的朋友也在和他们一起努力，以便更好地完成家庭作业，并保持联系。其他人则真的很挣扎，我认为这是我们需要摆脱平均值，开始关注个体的地方。欧洲正在进行非常出色的研究，这被称为“Awesome幸福项目”，他们采取了一种“N=1”（个体）的方法，发现一些年轻人确实（大约10%）发现使用社交媒体会让他们更焦虑，例如。
percent find that using social media can make them more anxious for example and there's another group about the same size that using social media can be really really valuable for them, right, from a point like creativity, co-to-connectedness. And there's a whole bunch of people in the middle that it has no effect at all. There's zero correlation. And so I think this is another thing where we need to start thinking about the individuals, what they're doing and how it's working psychologically in their life. And I think for parents, that's an important way to start thinking about.
还有另一组大约相同规模的人发现，使用社交媒体对他们来说真的非常有价值，比如从创造力、社会联系的角度来看。中间还有一大群人，它根本没有任何影响。相关性为零。所以我认为这是我们需要开始考虑个体的另一个方面，他们正在做什么，以及它在他们的生活中如何发挥心理作用。我认为对于家长来说，这是一个开始思考的重要方式。
Instead of just how much time, right, or how frequently they're using it, which is a kind of addiction model, instead thinking about how functional is it? Is it working? What are they doing? What skills are they getting? Are they, you know, staying connected? And I think that's a more healthy approach to tech use. So it sounds like you're looking at what people are doing when they're online. Are you looking at attention span? It seems that one of the things that's happening to us is that we're all over the place because we're distracted. You know, you look at one thing. There's that you got an article. It's got five links in it. Pretty soon you've gone down some rabbit hole and you don't know how you got there. Right. Kim, I fully get that. I sense my attention changing as well. And that is a concern. But I kind of try to think of the longer arc of, say, psychological history. And, you know, a good story to Anchores is Socrates. And he was really adamant about a technology of that time because he was worried about its effect on human memory, which to him was very much about the human soul. And that was the alphabet. He really believed that by writing things down, we would no longer remember them in the same way. And back there you'd have poets that would be trained to, you know, remember multi-hundred-line poems. We don't get our kids to do that anymore, but I don't
而不是仅仅关注时间，对吧，或者他们使用的频率，这是一种成瘾模型，而是思考它的功能性如何？它有效吗？他们在做什么？他们获得了什么技能？他们是否保持了联系？我认为这是一种更健康的科技使用方法。所以听起来您是在关注人们在线时在做什么。您在关注注意力跨度吗？似乎发生在我们身上的一件事是，我们因为分心而无处不在。你知道，你看一件事。那儿有一篇文章，里面有五个链接。很快你就钻进某个兔子洞，不知道自己是怎么进去的。没错。金，我完全理解。我也感觉到我的注意力在改变。这是一个担忧。但我试着从更长的时间跨度，比如心理学历史的角度来思考。你知道，一个锚定这个观点的好故事是苏格拉底。他非常坚持当时的一种技术，因为他担心它对人类记忆的影响，对他来说，记忆很大程度上关乎人类灵魂。那就是字母表。他真的相信，通过把事情写下来，我们将不再以同样的方式记住它们。在那之前，你会训练诗人去记住几百行的诗。我们不再让我们的孩子那样做了，但我认为
think anybody would say, well, let's get rid of the alphabet because we can't do 900-line poems. So, yes, I do, I would strongly believe that the way we are using technology, our media environment is changing our brain, it's changing our neuropsychology. And one negative outcome, I think, for me especially, is I feel like I'm pretty easily distracted. Like doing 20 minutes of writing on one of my papers, I put a timer down now. So I just stay focused on that for 20 minutes. And then I want to change it up.
没有人会说：“好吧，让我们摆脱字母表，因为我们做不到900行的诗。”所以，是的，我强烈认为我们使用技术的方式、我们的媒体环境正在改变我们的大脑，正在改变我们的神经心理学。一个负面结果，尤其是对我个人而言，是我觉得我很容易分心。比如在我的论文上写20分钟，我现在会定个计时器。所以我只是专注于那20分钟。然后我想换个花样。
But perhaps that's allowing me to deal with a whole bunch of other kinds of information in our new kind of media environment. Perhaps there's some cost, but we're adapting and we have benefits there. Are there other ways that we can incorporate social media into our lives that will maximize the benefits and minimize the harms? Well, I love the way you put that. I think that is the exact way to be thinking about it. And I don't have really high-level advice other than for each person, each family, to think about the degree to which this is beneficial for me and costly.
但也许这让我能够处理我们新媒体环境中的一大堆其他信息。也许有一些代价，但我们正在适应，并且我们从中获得了好处。还有其他方法可以将社交媒体融入我们的生活，从而最大化收益并最小化危害吗？嗯，我喜欢你提出这个问题的方式。我认为这正是思考它的方式。除了建议每个人、每个家庭思考这对我是有益的还是代价高昂的之外，我没有真正高水平的建议。
There's been a number of studies that show that, you know, people that are really showing kind of problematic internet use, say over using Facebook, they're often dealing with some other life stress, like they've lost a family member, they've lost a job, they're going through a divorce, or they're had some kind of financial issues. And so rather than thinking, like, what is social media doing to that person, it'd be more like, what is that, why is that person using it in that way? What are they trying to deal with? And for many people, It can be quite functional. It can be, I'm trying to deal with this.
有许多研究表明，那些表现出某种问题性互联网使用的人，比如过度使用Facebook，他们通常正在处理其他生活压力，比如他们失去了家庭成员、失去了工作、正在经历离婚，或者有某种经济问题。所以与其思考“社交媒体对那个人做了什么”，不如思考“为什么那个人以那种方式使用它？他们试图处理什么？”对许多人来说，
I'm trying to get through it. There are a small number of people, a small part of the population, which it's problematic. And it could be social media. It could be video games where they've just doing it so much that it's interfering with other parts of their lives. And so I like that kind of approach that you just mentioned, which is how do you optimize?
这可能非常有功能性。这可能是“我正在尝试处理这件事”。我正在努力度过难关。有一小部分人，人口的一小部分，这确实是有问题的。这可能是社交媒体。这可能是视频游戏，他们做得太多以至于干扰了他们生活的其他部分。所以我喜欢你刚才提到的那种方法，即如何优化？
How do you maximize the benefits and reduce the cost? I kind of think it was like driving cars. cars are far more deadly than social media way more and in the past we're even more so but we you know created new tech there's airbags we created regulations you have to wear seat belts you know that we created new norms you can't smoke in a car with your kids like you know but when i was growing up that's what every parent did it was not a problem now if somebody tried to do that that would be you know it would not be okay so our tech changes our our policy and regulation changes and our social behaviors change. And it makes cars much safer. Are they perfect? No, but we're optimizing. We're
如何最大化收益并减少成本？我有点认为这就像开车。汽车比社交媒体致命得多，多得多，过去甚至更是如此。但我们创造了新技术，有安全气囊，我们制定了法规，你必须系安全带，你知道，我们创造了新的规范，你不能在有孩子的情况下在车里吸烟，你知道，但我成长的时候，那是每个家长都会做的事，那不是问题。现在如果有人试图那样做，那会是……那是不可以的。所以我们的技术改变了我们的政策和法规，我们的社会行为也发生了改变。这使得汽车安全得多。它们完美吗？不，但我们正在优化。我们
creating the most benefit from the cars we can and minimizing the cost. And there's still work to be done. Most cars produce carbon and that's not good for our well-being in the long term either, and we're working on that. So I think it's an ongoing thing that people need to just focus on the way they're using their tech to think about how is this beneficial for them. So one of your more recent research interests is how artificial intelligence has begun to affect the conversations that people have with each other. This is a really interesting idea that I suspect a lot of people haven't really thought about. How is artificial intelligence injecting itself into our conversations and what effect does it have? Right. I think it's fascinating too, Kim, so I'm glad you do as well.
从汽车中创造了最大的利益，并最小化了成本。还有工作要做。大多数汽车产生碳排放，从长远来看这对我们的幸福感也不好，我们正在努力解决这个问题。所以我认为这是一个持续的过程，人们只需要关注他们使用技术的方式，思考这对他们如何有益。所以您最近的研究兴趣之一是人工智能如何开始影响人们之间的对话。这是一个非常有趣的想法，我怀疑很多人并没有真正考虑过。人工智能是如何注入到我们的对话中的？它有什么影响？没错。我也觉得这很迷人，金，所以我很高兴你也这么认为。
Most people think about when we talk with an Amazon machine or an Apple, Siri, that's not what I'm talking about. I'm talking about the way that we use AI to talk to each other. So AI sitting between humans. So when you and I were trying to figure out when we were going to have this conversation, my email would suggest, say, three things. If you had said, how about Monday at noon? It might say, sounds good. Talk to you then. or no, I can't. Very simple. When I look at them, they seem like, yeah, one of those would
大多数人想到我们与亚马逊机器或苹果Siri交谈时，那不是我所说的。我说的是我们使用人工智能彼此交谈的方式。所以人工智能坐在人类之间。所以当你和我试图弄清楚我们什么时候进行这次对话时，我的电子邮件会建议，比如三件事。如果你说：“周一中午怎么样？”它可能会说：“听起来不错。到时候聊。”或者“不，我不行。”非常简单。当我看着它们时，它们看起来像，“是的，其中一个会
fit the bill. It looks like there's about 16 billion of those messages sent every day just through Google's platform. Now we see places like Microsoft that have introduced auto-complete sentences in Word. We're seeing it in text messaging, auto-correct, auto-predict. And so what's happening is when I go to talk to you in a immediate environment, I'm giving suggestions on what to say. And those suggestions often feel really right. But what we know from the way human language is produced is that when I see language or hear language, it primes my semantic network space. So it actually activates some concepts.
合适。”看起来每天通过谷歌平台发送的消息大约有160亿条。现在我们看到像微软这样的公司在Word中引入了自动补全句子。我们在短信、自动更正、自动预测中也看到了这一点。所以发生的事情是，当我在一个媒介环境中和你交谈时，我得到了关于说什么的建议。而这些建议通常感觉非常正确。但我们从人类语言产生的方式中知道，当我看到语言或听到语言时，它会启动我的语义网络空间。所以它实际上激活了一些概念。
So that's how we can speak so quickly back and forth is we kind of become aligned linguistically with what language we're reading or hearing. So when I'm shown sounds good or no problem, it might feel right. It might feel like what I would have said, but I can't know because my brain has been primed to think those are reasonable things to say. And what's even crazier is, let's say you're using some system that never uses AI, never allows AI to be part of it. You don't have the options. But I use Sounds Good Talk to You then and send that over to you.
这就是我们能够如此快速地来回交谈的原因，我们与我们正在阅读或听到的语言在语言上保持了一致。所以当我看到“听起来不错”或“没问题”时，它可能感觉是对的。它可能感觉像我会说的话，但我无法知道，因为我的大脑已经被启动去认为那些是合理的说法。更疯狂的是，假设你正在使用某种从不使用人工智能、从不允许人工智能成为其一部分的系统。你没有这些选项。但我使用“听起来不错，到时候聊”并发送给你。
Well, now you've been primed by AI, even though you have no knowledge of it. There's no representation of that, but your brain has been changed. Okay, so does it matter? Well, it's at scale, so we're getting $16 billion, and that's certainly a low estimate because that's just Google. What we've found is some work done at Cornell by Maltai Young and Just Holstein, and also we've replicated here at Stanford with Hannah Mitch Kowsky, finding that these AI systems tend to be overly positive.
好吧，现在你已经被人工智能启动了，即使你对此一无所知。没有对此的表征，但你的大脑已经被改变了。好吧，这重要吗？嗯，它是大规模的，所以我们有160亿条，这肯定是一个低估，因为那只是谷歌。我们在康奈尔大学由马尔泰·杨和贾斯特·霍尔斯坦所做的一些研究中发现，我们也在斯坦福与汉娜·米奇科夫斯基一起复制了这些发现，即这些人工智能系统往往过于积极。
What I mean there is that sounds. good, sounds great. Those are much more common in the AI suggested messages than what humans would use. And we've done these in experiments, we've looked at the actual Google messages themselves. And it makes sense. If you're a corporation, you want to screw up that asymmetry of effect one way. You want to overdo the positive, right? And not more often say, no, you're an idiot. So that's smart on the but when you have more positivity being injected into language at the scale of Google, it raises real questions about what does that mean to our emotional tone? Is it appropriate? Is it
我的意思是，“听起来不错”、“听起来很棒”。这些在人工智能建议的消息中比人类会使用的要常见得多。我们已经在实验中做过这些，我们查看了谷歌消息本身。这是有道理的。如果你是一家公司，你想把这种效果的不对称性向一个方向倾斜。你想过度积极，对吧？而不是更频繁地说：“不，你是个白痴。”所以这在商业上很聪明。但当谷歌规模的语言中注入了更多的积极性时，它就引发了关于这对我们的情感基调意味着什么的真正问题。它合适吗？它
going to change the way we're thinking? And then there's other big questions like what what kind of discourse are those systems being trained on? If it's around trust, for example, then you know, we know that older white male discourse, right? The old Walter Cron kind type style of discourse is the most trusted in our society. If the AI is being trained on that kind of language, then it's going to prioritize, you know, white male discourse. And so there's real big ethical questions here as well when we're using AI to inject into human to human communication. And I think it's a fascinating area. You know, it has a lot of potential for good, but I'm frankly a little alarmed at how invisible it is and
会改变我们的思维方式吗？然后还有其他大问题，比如这些系统是在什么样的语篇上训练的？例如，如果它是关于信任的，那么你知道，我们知道年长的白人男性的语篇，对吧？那种老式的沃尔特·克朗凯特风格的语篇是我们社会中最受信任的。如果人工智能是在那种语言上训练的，那么它就会优先考虑白人男性的语篇。所以当我们使用人工智能注入人与人之间的交流时，这里也有真正重大的伦理问题。我认为这是一个迷人的领域。你知道，它有很大的潜力向好，但我坦率地说，我对它有多隐形感到有点震惊，
how at scale it is. Like putting Prozac in the water, right? Right. Oh, that's good. That'll be the title of our next paper. So obviously, as we've been chatting here, it's clear that technology changes really quickly. Is there anything that people aren't thinking about much now
以及它的规模有多大。就像在水里放百忧解，对吧？没错。哦，那很好。那将是我们下一篇论文的标题。所以很明显，正如我们在这里聊天时所看到的，技术变化非常快。有什么人们现在不太考虑，但您认为将成为下一个大问题的事情吗？我认为我一直在思考未来的两件事正是我们刚才谈到的，这个人工智能、媒体交流的想法，人工智能被用来帮助人类与其他人交谈。现在有新技术出来，技术专家知道很多，但我认为大多数人不知道，这被称为GPT-3。这是一个自然语言生成系统。它在它能编写的语言种类上确实令人印象深刻。
that you think will be the next big question? I think the two things I've been thinking a lot about for the future is exactly what we were just talking about, this idea of AI, media communication, AI being used to help humans talk to other humans. There's new tech out that technologists know a lot about, but I think most folks don't, which is called GPT3. This is a natural language generation system. And it is truly impressive on the kinds of language it can write.
所以你在你感兴趣的任何领域、内容领域训练它，然后它就会产生新的内容。我认为它为虚假信息提出了问题。现在你必须付钱给人们一点钱才能散布大量虚假信息。有了像GPT-3这样的东西，你基本上是在以非常低的成本寻找无限量的虚假信息。所以有这些事情。此外，如果你是一名年轻学生，并且你对市场营销感兴趣，例如，
So you train it up on whatever area, content area you're interested in, and then it produces new content. I think it raises questions for disinformation. Now you have to pay people a little bit to get a bunch of disinformation out there. With something like GPT3, you're looking at essentially infinite amount of disinformation for really low cost. So there's these kind of things. Also, if you're a young student and you're interested in marketing, for example,
你知道，GPT-3将被用来以低得多的价格创造海量的营销内容。所以，你知道，如果你现在毕业并从事品牌管理，而你不知道人工智能如何创造语言，我认为你会有麻烦。所以这些是处于风口浪尖的事情。有很多值得担心的事情，也有很多值得兴奋的事情。另一件事让我们回到了我们之前谈到的Zoom疲劳。很明显，我们一直在交谈的大多数大公司都有兴趣在未来采用混合模式。这有很多原因，从成本到减少碳排放，你知道，所有这些事情。但公司担心文化，他们的企业
you know, GPD3 will be used to create, you know, massive amounts of marketing for a much lower price. And so, you know, if you're into brand management graduating right now and you don't know about how AI can create language, you're going to be in trouble, I think. So those are things that are right at the cusp. And there's lots of things to be worried about, lots of things to be excited. The other brings us back to the Zoom fatigue that we were talking about earlier. it's pretty clear that most large companies that we've been talking to are interested in a hybrid model going forward. And there's lots of reasons for it from, you know, costs to reducing carbon, you know, all these things. But companies are worried about culture, their kind of corporate
文化。他们担心引入年轻人并让他们在组织内为人所知。所以我认为视频将长期存在。一个问题是，我们如何从仅仅是这种视频，即你被看到进入我的客厅，我被看到进入你的办公室，转变为其他模式？没有真正的组织。如果你来到我在斯坦福的办公室，你会看到书架，会有一张桌子，我们会知道事情在那里是如何进行的。
culture. They're worried about bringing young people in and having them, you know, get known within an organization. So I think video is here to stay. And one question is, how do we move from just this video where you're seen into my living room? I'm seen into your office. There's no real organization. If you were to come into my office at Stanford, you would see bookshelf and there'd be a desk and we would kind of know how things are going there.
文化。他们担心引入年轻人，并让他们在组织内建立知名度。所以我认为视频将会持续存在。一个问题是，我们如何从这种仅仅让你出现在我的客厅、让我出现在你的办公室的视频交流，转变为更深层的互动。目前并没有真正的组织感。如果你来到我在斯坦福的办公室，你会看到书架和办公桌，我们就能大概了解那里的情况。
We've just sort of opened our homes into business. And so I think there's a lot of things to be done here around VR. So how will virtuality help us incorporate culture at a distance? We'll see changes in the way that Zoom conferences or video conferences are done. So I think we'll see big improvements in technology. And also kind of institutional changes. Let's not have Zoom or video conferences as a default all the time. Let's use it when it's important or necessary.
我们刚刚把家变成了办公室。所以我认为在虚拟现实领域还有很多事情要做。那么虚拟现实将如何帮助我们远程融入文化呢？我们将看到Zoom会议或视频会议方式的改变。所以我认为我们将看到技术的巨大进步，以及制度上的变革。让我们不要总是默认使用Zoom或视频会议，只在重要或必要时使用它。
And I think there's going to be more of a sense of, what's the right word, more of a sense of investment in people and their places if we're going to ask people to stay home. And so, you know, we'll start seeing corporations, I think, invest in people's home offices and do it in a ways that will help support that that culture that they're very interested in keeping. So I'm, yeah, I'm excited for the future. I think we've opened up a new kind of way of working together and connecting that could be healthier for the planet, healthier for us individually. But it just is a doesn't have to be video conference all the time.
我认为，如果我们要求人们待在家里，人们会更有——怎么说呢——更有对员工及其住所进行投入的感觉。所以，你知道，我认为我们将开始看到企业投资员工的家庭办公室，并以有助于支持他们非常希望保持的那种文化的方式进行投资。所以我对未来感到兴奋。我认为我们开启了一种新的工作和联系方式，这对地球更健康，对我们个人也更健康。但这并不意味着必须一直进行视频会议。
I'm trying to figure out how we're going to come up with some sort of a hybrid model that works, you know, so that when some people are in the office and some people are not, like what's happening with kids in school right now, right, where the teacher is so busy dealing with the Zoom kids that she's not dealing with the kids who are in the room. Right. And are we going to experience something like that when we go back to work? Those hybrid situations where there's some people in person and some people not are the most difficult for sure because the ones that aren't there are a little less visible.
我正在努力想出一种行之有效的混合模式，你知道，这样当一些人在办公室而另一些人不在时，就像现在学校里的孩子们所经历的那样，老师忙于应付Zoom上的孩子，以至于没法顾及在教室里的孩子。对吧？当我们回到工作岗位时，我们会经历类似的情况吗？那些有人在现场、有人不在的混合情况肯定是最困难的，因为不在场的人存在感会稍微低一些。
And I think that's where we might see some good advances in technology. You know, there's likely to be changes where I can put some glasses on and see another person who's not here right now, but the glasses make sort of visible or at least salient, not perfectly, but at least will remind me that they're here. They're part of this conversation. Well, this has all been really interesting. I appreciate you taking the time to talk to us, Dr. Hancock. It's been a pleasure to talk to you.
我认为这正是我们可能会看到技术取得一些良好进展的地方。你知道，很可能会出现这样的变化：我可以戴上眼镜，看到一个现在不在这里的人，但眼镜让对方变得可见，或者至少是显著的，虽然不完美，但至少会提醒我他们在这里，他们是这次谈话的一部分。好吧，这一切都非常有趣。感谢您抽出时间与我们交谈，汉考克博士。很高兴与您交谈。
Thanks, Kimberly. I really enjoyed the conversation. You can find previous episodes of Speaking of Psychology at www. www. speakingof psychology.org or on Apple, Stitcher, or wherever you get your podcasts. And please leave us a review. If you have comments or ideas for future podcasts, you can email us at speaking of psychology at APA.org. That's Speaking of Psychology, all one way.
谢谢你，金伯利。我很享受这次谈话。你可以在www.speakingofpsychology.org或Apple、Stitcher以及你获取播客的任何地方找到《心理学谈话》往期节目。请给我们留下评论。如果你对未来的播客有任何意见或想法，可以发送电子邮件至speakingofpsychology@apa.org。那是Speaking of Psychology，连在一起写。
Word at APA.org. Speaking of psychology is produced by Lee Weinerman. Our sound editor is Chris Kondyian. Thank you for listening. For the American Psychological Association, I'm Kim Mills. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
在APA.org。 《心理学谈话》由李·韦纳曼制作。我们的声音编辑是克里斯·康迪安。感谢您的收听。我是金·米尔斯，代表美国心理学会。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。